das liegt mir besonders am herzen die
schulen philipp wie geht es mit den
schulen weiter denn dort haben wir auch
immer noch eine ganz große gruppe von
kindern bis zwölf jahre die nicht
geimpft werden können völlig richtig da
hat uns die bundesregierung in form der
kanzlerin in form von vizekanzler olaf
scholz ja versprochen die schulen sind
das letzte was wir schließen wenn
überhaupt und das erste was wir öffnen
das versprechen wurde natürlich längst
gebrochen jetzt wird es wirklich ins
gegenteil verkehrt man schließt zwar
schon lockt es flächendeckend aus aber
durch die hintertür werden natürlich
schulen auch dicht gemacht und zwar
durch die quarantäne des rk ii das haben
wir aus einer internen sitzung erfahren
hat gefordert dass pro infiziertem kind
die ganze schulklasse in quarantäne geht
wir haben zahlen aus brandenburg
bekommen wo die frau von olaf scholz
britta ernst bildungsministerin ist dann
geht im schnitt gerade pro infiziertem
kind gehen 13 kinder für zwei wochen in
quarantäne
das sind schulschließung durch die
hintertür und dann kann sich nicht mal
frei testen das muss man noch mal ganz
deutlich sagen also kinder eltern
geschwister sitzen dann zwei wochen
feste nicht am unterricht teilnehmen
völlig richtig kinder die selbst kaum
gefährdet sind durch corona die so
zeigen es studien mittlerweile auch
weniger ansteckend sind die werden so
hart bestraft wie gerade niemand ich
kann mich von so vielem in deutschland
frei testen auch wenn ich aus hochrisiko
ländern als urlauber zurück komme aber
als ich darf mein kind nicht fressen
muss es zwei wochen zu hause behalten
das ist übrigens nicht nur eine
schulschließung durch die hintertür das
heißt auch dass die eltern diese zwei
wochen lang nicht richtig arbeiten
können also und das ist nicht corona
dass uns das diktiert nicht die pandemie
gegen die wir nichts tun können das sind
regierungsmaßnahmen warum das warum ist
sehr interessant warum trifft man eine
solche alltags regelung das geht ja
jetzt los jetzt laufen wir langsam in
den herbst rein jetzt kommen so die
erste erkältungswelle jetzt kommen mehr
kinder in die schulen mit symptomen
jetzt schlagen die test langsam an man
hört immer mehr im verwandten
angehörigen kreis von solchen fällen das
eben klassen geschlossen werden das
heißt das wird jetzt tatsächlich ganz
akut das ist jeden tag alltag für ganz
ganz viele kinder und deren aber warum
macht man das so warum tritt eine so ja
relativ alltags fremde regelung für die
schulen für die eltern für die kinder
ich bin wirklich sprachlos nach diesen
anderthalb jahren das sind sowohl viele
reden die immer gehalten werden dass es
um die zukunft der kinder geht dass
kinder immer vorrang immer priorität
haben deutschland hat sich als eines der
kinderfreundlichsten länder wiesen und
zumindest haben wir die
kinderfreundlichste regierung gerne mal
glaube ich hat das ganz anders gemacht
hat dann im ersten lockdown ja auch noch
komplett zugemacht auch die schulen und
dann schon aber im vergangenen herbst
einen ganz anderen weg gewählt richtig
dänemark aber auch die schweiz hat
schulen nach dem ersten lok tor nicht
mehr zugemacht frankreich hat auch
schulen viel viel länger offen gelassen
und stattdessen home office und so
weiter eingeführt also es ging so vielen
ländern darum kindern den
schulunterricht zu ermöglichen weil man
ja auch weiß dass das auch
gesundheitliche folgen hat wenn kinder
nicht spielen wenn kinder nicht lernen
wenn kinder gerade in sozial schwachen
familien den ganzen tag zu hause
eingesperrt sind aber deutschland hat
sich immer wenn es möglich war für
schulschließung entschieden und das
haben die geologen auch gemacht die die
kanzlerin beraten haben das haben auch
wie ich finde
gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach
gemacht aber es ging auch immer zentral
aus dem kanzleramt heraus von angela
merkel von helge braun die haben im
zweifel erst mal die schulen dicht
gemacht aber draußen etwas anderes
erzählt wie android heißt ein kindern no
schule also es ist es eine kein
unterricht unglaublich ich finde es
wirklich unfassbar ich blicke wirklich
mit großer sorge in den herbst und
winter ich habe drei kinder und mal
sehen wie viele da überhaupt in kita und
schule in diesem winter an diesem herbst
gehen können wenn so schnell wieder
dicht gemacht wird
[Musik]